TO BE ASHAMED OF.
IT'S SAD SOMEONE MUST LOSE THIS
BUT IT'S A PART OF THE SPORT.
BUT THEY ARE DEVOTING ALL THEIR
ENERGY TO THIS GAME, BOTH TEAMS.
OFF THE TIEUP IS IT FAIR BUT IT
CAME BACK TO YANDLE, BLOCKED BY
GIRARDI.
GOAL!
>> Eddie: WELL, THE GAME-WINNING
GOAL IN OVERTIME, DEREK STEPAN.
WE TALK ABOUT HOW THE RANGERS
ARE A TEAM THAT WON MORE FACEOFF
PLAYS IN THE NATIONAL HOCKEY
LEAGUE.
OFFENSIVE ZONE, NEUTRAL ZONE,
DEFENSIVE ZONE.
THIS WAS ONE OF THOSE PLAYS.
THE FACEOFF WIN, GOOD HELP THERE
FROM FAST, YANDLE TO THE POINT,
THE SHOT FROM GIRARDI BIG
REBOUND, HOLTBY COULD NEVER GET
BACK TO HIS FEET AND THE
REACTION FROM DEREK STEPAN AND
THE RANGERS MOVE TO THE EAST
CONFERENCE FINAL.
AND THE REACTION FROM HENRIK
LUNDQVIST.
AND FROM THE RANGERS BENCH.